hello everyone I
welcome you to this
virtual conference of sifar it is part of a
new series of events intended
to highlight how research
can inform decision-
making research
we of course felt in  public health
but also in computer science and in
many fields of the
humanities and social sciences in economics in
anthropology in geography so
starting research bombs can help
decision-makers make their decision at
a key moment when governments are
starting to reopen the economies
that we were  paralyzed as we
know by that coitus 19
so if you don't know the
whistler it's a
global charity based in
canada that brings together the brightest
minds from around the world to look
at important
issues facing science
and humanity and like many other
organizations around the globe, cifa
of course  had to adapt quickly to
fight against the copying of 19 and
launch new initiative projects that we
hope to highlight in this
series so when to me I am antoine
petit you understood from my accent that
I was French I am the  i am a
professor of computer science but i
am perhaps especially worried at the moment
president director general of the cnrs which
is therefore the major
french national multidisciplinary research center
public research organizations
but i am also a member of
the sifar research council and whose  the mandate
is to advise the president and the
general manager on the formulation the
creation and establishment
of high quality advanced research programs
a site on the conclusion of these
programs once their mission has been
accomplished and it is my great pleasure to
introduce you to professor yeshua
benjo the choice holds a
chair in haiti jean sarti sky canada
si lighthouse in center- milla  he is
also co-director of the
machine learning
biological learning program of sifar and professor at
the university of montreal
he is one of
the most respected computer scientists in the world
by pioneers of deep learning
and he in particular winner of the
prestigious prize  turing 2018 with his
two colleagues jacking tons and yann le
15 and the turing prize is considered in a
certain way as the nobel prize
for computing and this award is
quite exceptional and our choices
and will envy us amossy later
also led the development of covile
applications for
smartphones which aims to trace
contacts and predict the risk
of infection for him as I am told
before starting I remind you that
today's session will last approximately
30  minutes and I am going to take advantage of my
role as chairman of the meeting to
start asking the
first questions, but you can
then contributed to these questions in
place using the question
and answer function and he therefore did not hesitate to
submit your questions
and finally I remind you that it is
them it is lens is recorded will be
available on the website of s  '
do it next week without further
ado I'm going to pass the floor to
comes choice first the choice thank you a
lot of heads join us and then
I'm going to attack the subject directly and
I think it's important that you
start with  finally clarify
what is the purpose of these
contact tracing applications like the one you
have unlocked but as others have
developed around the world we
will perhaps come back to this and perhaps because
it was a specialty that she  is what
is the role of
artificial intelligence in such applications
and did deep learning
kill a specialist on Thursday a role to
play in his
applications okay thank you very much antoine and thank you
for these good words so first of all
the use of
telephone technology to reduce the spread
of the virus
the idea is to be able to
give information to people who
may be contagious before it
infects someone  a back because
today we are dealing with a virus
that is very different from other other
contagious diseases and in particular
pesky characteristics that
people are going to be contagious for
about two days before they even have
symptoms is  in fact the peak of
contagiousness comes before the onset of
symptoms personally or people
start to have symptoms they
will suspect that they are being
contagious and in general they change
their behavior they will
distance themselves more attention
is therefore needed  large part of the infections
is in this moment when people
just don't know who are at
risk
so the different applications will
use the knowledge of q  who has
met who to be able to spread
the information between those for whom
we have information the person has
symptoms the person has had a
positive diagnosis and those who for the moment
do not yet know that they are contagious
but who  have been in contact with these
people for whom we know a
little more that they are contagious
so in the binary screening code
the classic we find almost everywhere
in the world such as in France and
many countries
what we are trying  to do is
simply detect whether you are in
the risk category or not depending
on whether you have been in contact in the
last two weeks with someone
who has had a positive test or a
positive diagnosis are in  general that
these diagnoses that will happen
maybe
a week after the first symptoms
because people don't
necessarily have sufficient testing capacity
the legs we are waiting
for the symptoms to be more serious and
moreover it takes time to carry out
tests it then takes time with
manual screening so that the people who
have been in contact with these
positive people receive the information so
the telephones make it possible to speed up that a
little bit who were using the
tracing of contacts that took
place through the telephone
using fairly secure methods there, which is from the
point of view of the protection of
privacy, is not perfect either, it is
impossible to have perfection in this
sense  where
artificial intelligence comes into play is that we
can use information other than
the fact of having had a positive diagnosis
to transmit a signal to someone
with whom we have been in contact, in
particular if we have  symptoms according to
the severity of the symptoms the type of
symptoms and its ranks we have a certain
probability of being sick and this
information there is this probability
of being sick can be calculated on
our phone is  sent to the
phone people who have the application and
with whom we have been in contact and
themselves even before even my drawing
sheep because there are a few days
after we are infected during
which we are not yet
infectious  and so if we can send a
message during this window we can
have a big impact on the spread
of the virus
so that's when it came out in
the air intervenes it intervenes to
predict the risk according to all
the indices  ranging from the clues to
perhaps leaving half time as I said
that perhaps the agglomeration of all the
risks that we took by being close to
people who themselves had a
circus a level of risk and so on
so it  is the behavior is that we
take public transport is that
we put on a mask is unstable and even
often etc which can also play and
we can ask people our questions
to refine this pre this
time estimate of the risk and can  -be  let's
continue in this direction
not everyone is a
deep learning specialist but to
learn you have to taste data is
finished
before as clerk 19 and
something new how did you have
rules how did you succeed  to have
this data which therefore makes it possible
to learn and to have a
more precise diagnosis than the binary diagnosis
which is sometimes done very good question
therefore indeed to be able to predict
an event like the fact of being
contagious of being carriers of the virus and
its errors we need data that
associates the information available at the
time we would like to make a
prediction is what we want predicts the
fact of having the virus, for example
at the start we obviously do not have this
data there but we have  other
data epidemiological data from
epidemiological models that simulates
what can happen in daily life
when people walk around transporting
from place to place  work go
to school in front of the hospital spend
some time close to each other and
we have built such a model and
colleagues for example in England have
also built similar models
which make it possible to test different
communication strategies between
information phones and therefore with
its technological models we can
simulate what would happen if people,
given a prediction that
concerns them, decides to change their
behavior and how that could
affect the contagions that would happen
that would not happen so that's  is the
first step
and it already allows us to assess how
different approaches can
compare with each other they have in a
theoretical way because these models
it's not reality it's like a
physical model it's for reality
but these are approximations that are
commonly used in epidemiology
the second thing is that from the
moment a system like that would be
deployed  ed we can measure on the
phone all the information that they
serve as input for the prediction and
then when someone receives a
positive test we can also record this
information and it will constitute a
database to train a
predictor more  end which not
only use the few dozen studies
so we owe us
some constants and physiological there
for assimilation but
something much more precise in fact it would make it
possible to look for data
on a scale which for the moment
n  does not exist in the
epidemiological study of the disease it
would also allow us to better
understand the disease and make
better risk predictions there
are issues of privacy because that
means that people must
also consent if they  want to share this
data where we can train it
is a risk predictor it is this
private life aspect a soul between the important had
the knowledge that perhaps the  s monitors the
sand it was the subject of a certain
number of controversies in France that
how how we respond to people who
say yes but in the end the damage
is less than the benefits because
if I understand correctly there again it is not
binary  that is to say that an application
to trace necessarily is obliged to
leave some data
but basically you have to be able to weigh the
pros and cons
so what do you answer to people
who aim that the control bears  on the
back to the bottom I think that we must have a
calm democratic debate respectful and
inform so that we decide together in
each country which of German on the scale
of the planet
points in May to its different
values  what people's lives are
more or less important than
privacy then it's not all black or
white because privacy is not
that we lose it completely,
for example the techniques we
developed with kovy go  protect the
data as well as the way in
which data in a hospital is protected
so we are not talking about adding a higher level of
risk than what already exists
people are also using
applications with bluetooth and so
on on their phones already a lot
so there  you have to understand
what are the new risks that are
added who understands the advantages for
the moment to understand the advantages
what we have in terms
of rice production it's only
simulations so we would have to  'we
make pilots these pilots would have to
be on a sufficiently large scale
to be statistically valid to be
able to assess in real life that it had
what degree of how many visas will
finally be and not then be able to
make this judgment there is what you
have  also studies in the
simulation camp on finally what is
the percentage of people who must
use such an application for
it to be very effective  it hasn't yet if I
compare with france this top cow quickly
that it pays when put on the market
about a week ago only 2% of
the French population has
downloaded it,
we don't even know very well  how much there is
how much she uses so there are people
who say so it's not effective
and others who say here it's better
than nothing so did
you have time to study how during  of
his there is not a simple answer to
this question for example it depends if
if you have 10% of the population which
uses the application but that these 10%
are concentrated in a few places is
for these places there it will be  very
effective
then we have to see what kind
of application we are talking about so if it is
vinegar tracing like what in
most countries there are indeed
studies which show that it would take
perhaps 60% of the population to
really  have a big impact but with
our calculations we show that yes but it is
not a threshold  if 50% is still useful
it's 40% because useful it's 30% are
still useful it's just that the usefulness is
decreasing so that's one thing the other
thing is that an application like
the one we had known built in
fact remains useful at a much
more basic level because it gives
information, for example, starting from the
symptoms and will help us to assess
our own risk even if I am in
communication with no one to be able to
assess  the risk I carry for
others from may behavior of
my symptoms there are dozens of
variations on its symptoms there it
is something useful either to
help people make their decisions
secondly an application like the one
that  we have developed who is not
only doing this spreading
of information and the telephones and who are
also going to look for data
to better understand the disease to
help public health has identified
where the outbreaks are coming at least  in
order to anticipate these outbreaks sas is
useful even if the percentage of the
population is low because
at that time we see look at aggregated information
on a lot of people or on
a region we don't need everyone
everyone in this region uses the application
if 10% of people were not going to the
region use the application well we will
still have a signal which will be
useful for public health
and if I want if I now place myself
from a point  of view all
communications between the star is
on bluetooth technologies and there
too there was in France and I think
it's the same with you a controversy
with decapolis so as not to hide it
that they considered that  ' he was preventing
us had a way the communication
all of us of this type of application
how did you or how did you
plan to solve this problem or so there
are several possible
solutions a solution is that we do we
asked apple  and google  e to change
their protocol in a way that we
consider really minor the touch not
to bluetooth but simply an offside
of consent I know it takes
time to go into the details but
it is in our opinion very small change
that  would have allowed which would allow the
background to run predictive models
with their interface
in the meantime or as an alternative to that we have
developed a
bluetooth proximity detection system based on the work
that has been done in England by the net
chessex and which has been tested  in the isle of
wight and which seems to be working really
well and actually even having
better phone coverage
than you could get with apple and
google in the sense that with the apple
google there are older phones
for  which for sure it
would not work because they
could not update the
operating system
I remind the listeners who can
ask the questions and that I will do
their  spokesperson but as a subject
that we have to address I am
very far behind since paris paris toronto
paris montreal is still not on
this side but I understood that in the end
the federal government had decided
not to  not retain kovy so I imagine that
it was a disappointment for all the
people who had spent a lot
of hours and probably a lot of
nights can you still
comment on this decision
I think the role of the
researchers  is to propose solutions with
their science with what is at the state
of technology in science who does not know
the role of researchers to make
decisions for the population the
government represents the population
they made this choice here in canada
I think  that they have their reasons I
can understand that it is easier to
explain that we are going to use the same
kind of application as what we do
in the United States for example in
many places now
and there is a fear  maybe the
fact of using
artificial intelligence it repels people so
there are arguments that can stand
me what concerns me the fact of being
able to save more lives and help
public health with information
precious to fight the virus
it should have won the round but
it's not up to us to make these
decisions there of course I think they
have that's why indeed as
you say that we don't confuse
politics and for that  to decide the
scientists to bring
expertise but when you are
absolutely right on the fact that it is not
for the scientists to decide it would be
a confusion of the genres is what
someone is therefore according to you even if
I imagine  is not completely simple
as a question b so in there in the
decision of the government that it is a
what is the part linked to the fact that
Canadians were ready or not to accept
this kind of application certainly there
again if I compare that  France has a
lot of controversy and a lot of
forums so the pros and cons
start as we like
discussions in France like end 5
it plays a role in this decision in
your opinion where it's more a technical decision
no I think it's  is very much a
political decision actually the
fear of putting forward
something which is then not followed by
enough people that we still see for
example in alberta where there is an
application which was launched at about
5%  of the population who downloaded
the application
so I believe that there is an issue of
succeeding in a political coup which is
important to understand each other
now if we are going well in the end
you have worked a lot while
everything has been equipped  and lots of people
around you what were the ultimately from a
scientific point of view
was it just an
engineering job or ultimately what were
the scientific obstacles that
posed the most problems to you?  e problems
ah I really like this question
because it's an example of the kind we
like to see where there is both an
application that is interesting and
useful for the public for society
but at the same time that they  pose
unprecedented scientific challenges so there the
kennedy scientific challenges at the level of
social vat at the level of machine learning
it was to work with the
constraints of privacy example if we
really wanted to be optimal in the
prediction of risk
we would have to  'we have access
to all the contacts who has been in
contact with whom when for
how long and their hours before the graph
of all their contacts
but that is privileged information that is
too dangerous we don't want
anyone  no government can have
access to this information so in fact
this information is implicit
in the telephone network but it
is never communicated it goes with
our system
so per  sounds can't know who was
who met who where when and so
we had to innovate in terms of
algorithms to strike this level of
risk with missing
information and others in the same genre  water
finally we do not have everything we
need to make a prediction but
how can we get out
of it from a technical point of view at the level
of the schools of learning to
still succeed in making  the predictions
and trained the system without having the
real answer
so there were kept several questions
about the listeners is one of the questions
a little civil peace on baie d'hyères which
is asked is what are
you ready for  the second wave
if unfortunately I play again add there
was this second wave in the fall
as some are afraid
we have our technologies ready we will
put our code in open source
fairly quickly and so I think that
after that it's healthy  debate a public debate
must who must co  continue if what
is in place
today with tracing let's say I
call binary doesn't work well
in different countries that there's a
second wave coming
maybe people will say to themselves is this  that we
could do better at that time maybe
the use of sky exit lands
will become something that
would be considered more seriously there
are clearly whose listeners
people who are supported if I may say
and who ask in a certain way
could the citizen or the
citizens help convince the
politicians, for example via a
consultation with them, we should perhaps
review the decision and imagine
the large-scale use of copies
I would very much like to, in fact, we are
considering  create this kind of
consultation and obviously there will
be polls possibly according to the
discussions in the media in
the public space but we among our
values ​​there is the question of giving
power  r to citizens
so in fact this kind of application if
they are well done at the level of the
protection of privacy
it is democratic tools or it is
not the government which decides for us
it is each citizen who decides to  doing
a bit of a part from a civic perspective
to protect your community and that
also means being part of a
published democratic discussion about the
pros and cons and the issues and hopefully we
'll have more of those  discussions in the
future and therefore in fact each of us obviously
our action today in this sense
there perhaps the municipality or remain only 5
minutes and time flies
is that because I recalled at the
very beginning that you are like  the great
specialist in deep learning
and the pundits of the sks
that artificial intelligence
is perhaps deep learning
beyond the tracing apps that
have been talked about a lot or was useful and
used during the pandemic
oh yes yes it  there's a lot  p a lot of
things that are being done
there are at the start there have already been several
articles that have come out on
the analysis, for example, of medical images
to help diagnose
even before the tests are done there
are studies that are being done to  better
understand the risk of patients so
for with the telephone but from
what is happening in the hospital
which patients are the ones who
should be taken care of as a priority, for
example so that we should put
in artificial respirators and  etcetera
myself I am involved in other
projects where we use deep learning
for the discovery of new
drugs or new combinations
of drugs
so here we use
machine learning deep learning to
quickly search efficiently
in space  molecular what is the most
promising to then pass these
candidates to biologists who will
test them because the sets of
combinations are
existing drugs or outright new
molecules and is too too big there
to test them all or really
test a fraction no weeks
ago promising early results
there have been studies that have identified
potential drugs at the
individual level already  it was done and I
think it influenced problems in
the clinical studies in progress where we
are today it is the combination of
two drugs
so that I do not think they have the
results are out but it will come
in the next few weeks the
next few months then also the
downright new drugs
which is interesting with
drug combinations knowing that it
will be faster to deploy because
we don't need to test whether these
molecules are dangerous we know  already
what are the side effects
so we only need to really
check that the combination of
drugs helps fight the disease
we must comp  to make that it is treatment
there in fact it is also a stopgap we
can say before the vaccine but a vaccine
there are many events which are
done around you but its real pestle
because good maybe  counter-report
quickly what worked even if
we find something that works
it has to be tested really
thoroughly because we cannot
afford to give a molecule to 99%
of the population who realize six
months more  late created half of the people
die because of it some
controversies in france on the subject
on others on certain molecules and I
believe that everyone at school
how much what you have achieved
while antivirals but we will  give
only to people who are already sick
and these questions of definition
new molecules or it is because the
challenges in new materials others
somewhat in the same type of research
does this pose for
dia specialists like you  news  here
again new questions
ah yeah absolutely it's an extraordinary mine
of questions not obvious
for example one of the questions that
interests me is how we
use reinforcement learning to
have a search strategy
in space  drugs
which takes into account the particularities of
this problem and which is different from
the use of
reinforcement learning in the applications that we
know like playing the game of go at
chess or betting and that poses
new problems that  'we don't know
how to explore this
space to use the fact that there is a
computing time issue in fact we are
in a kind of race against
time we have limited computing power
as we  uses this
computing power optimal hands to extract the
most information about the
possible candidates plays a channel must be
more than a minute so the flywheel
conclude there are several the question q  ui
come back to the kovy
application as a tracing application with
finally questions on how how
do we have to how can we
convince people is the application
not worse than that somewhat goes back to the
question we have  already had
is the ls whatever
the application is not worse than what
it withdraws from you at the end of freedom
at the faro tobacco one minute to
convince people that the next
time it will be necessary it will be necessary to vote for this
game
I'm taking a very simple example that is
not covered by
current tracking systems let's imagine that antoine
[Music]
was symptoms of the hill
and kick antoine and I saw each other
three days ago three days ago I was
infected  but i don't know it yet
i start three days later so a
moment when antoine starts to have
symptoms i start to be contagious
if it was possible that i am warned
that there is a danger that i am
because antoine declares  that he has
symptoms  my we could save a lot
of lives and we could do it by
taking no more risks with
privacy that I already understand as a
risk
listen I am at the mercy of a lot I
would be more than to organize a
consultation for the next wave
even if we wish everything that is
no next waves thank you to all the
participants there were more than
fifty participants so I
think we had a good audience
thank you thank you once again there is choice
thank you all and  to all and then see you
next time for a new
conference to get used to it
thank you very much at one see you soon